that's amazing taps radio playing the
latest Johnny Coltrane up on the case Oh
plant cam exclusive 975 man Ready Set
Radio pulled a cab live in studio we
have got a sure ah ah ah first things
first mr. Asher I'm an arizona cardinals
fan i know you're a Niners fan this is
true I would like to congratulate you on
thank you man it's been a long time
coming I'm a Niner hater but you know
what at least somebody from the NFC West
is like really good yeah at least Kurt
Warner's not wearing gloves anymore I
was alone oh man but yeah man a you got
the paps in jazz record that just came
out man and I've been sitting with the
last couple days and to drop in we've
been playing we do underground hip hop
show we've been playing on common
knowledge and in the kitchen and uh the
paps and jazz and the joint with Action
Bronson yeah great dude front to back
man Thank You Man I don't find your work
that's what we're trying to do is just
put out quality product I mean uh it's
been interesting to really kind of go
through the rod do the olive college
stuff and then without grind right it's
in a day and you know not really see
that get the same reception that I love
college did and then do you know have
the greenhouse effect and juicier foie
gras points and cranberry and that's
what J Dilla wu-tang yeah exactly so
this one that's cool to see kind of it
all be Coleman uh it's all it's all
coming together which is just basically
all right there's good rhymes there's
good beats and it's all come down to one
and it got a little loves yeah shout out
to the blended babies to shout out JP
rich gang shout out to Chicago really
holding me down on that they produced a
record there was like a group pulled
over by the cops or something moved up
freddie is cute kids yo they're gonna be
so happy when they hear that yeah man
full of that record we play that record
that record that's crazy yeah they're
they're absolute animals I'm really
excited for the blended babies are going
to be doing some really really big stuff
in 2012 most definitely now um there has
been quite the resurgence of a new white
rappers this year yeah a lot of new
white guys are
I feel like you were kind of like I was
I've been a fan since the greenhouse
effect like back when I was working at
Phoenix that was what about favorite
mixtapes um and I thought man I really
thought that human like the next guy to
blow onto my superstar ish and I really
was a I was kind of disappointed with
how people received the debut album you
know I think they kind of box you in as
a college right you know the content
with the new def jam situation you're
finally going to get the look that you
deserve as as an MC yeah i mean the
labels are labels and its really it's
amazing for me to be part of one loud
and steve rifkind yeah def jam so from a
historical standpoint it's like all
right word you know what I'm saying it's
great but uh most like storied really I
mean loud and and FG so that's cool from
that standpoint and just to have people
excited it's fresh now over at Def Jam
it's it's it's uh it's new for everybody
right also that's in my favor but at the
end of the day man it really comes down
to me and that's something that I've
learned is where when I first came out
the gate we had this huge record is just
like a lot of people were just how we'll
do it all for you right and I'm young so
I'm just like okay I trust you guys and
then you know I've taken a few steps
back and just thought about what do I
want to do where I want to take this
thing and uh and that's why I'm excited
about the Def Jam thing is because now
we have a historical label and
especially in the hip-hop world and
which is excited about me and now I have
a clear-cut vision of where I want to
take my music so I hope I just hope that
my fans are ready to be challenged by
listeners are ready to be challenged I'm
going to continue to challenge myself
obviously paps and jazz is new it sounds
new grain you know and that's the kind
of stuff that we're trying to do is just
continue to progress progression is kind
of key so yeah I mean with all the white
rappers and other things that's going on
that's cool I mean I look there's so
many now I almost just look at his
extract its yeah now it's just rappers
action rocks were you when you started
to pop like it was kind of like oh
there's a new white rapper and then now
it's just kind of like it's no because
everyone just looked at as emcees so
we'll see man I mean I said I'm just
trying to differentiate myself from the
from the package and just be jumping and
do cool stuff and that's it most
definitely um I also wanted to ask you I
know that you and you you've known
Justin Bieber for a minute I was talking
to scooter when he was up here he
and there might be a Justin Bieber
record on your album haha well it's def
possibly with someone whose name I crime
with from Ishmael you know it's it's a
it's a natural Roth record but justin
bieber's is the record is on that yet
man it's it's dope I mean we've uh
Justin and I have kind of a you know
grown up together for lack of better
words he was down in Atlanta with me and
we took care of him for a little bit and
watch you were like the babysitter to
the superstar that he is yeah man but
it's funny enough he's taught me he's
taught me so much man he taught me to
just be go get it you know I mean that
kid doesn't doubt himself for five
seconds he does it all one thing I seem
like kicking soccer balls Barcelona next
thing he's like scoring goals and
Toronto Maple Leafs jerseys and now he
has hit records too so he taught me a
lot about just like going and getting it
and just seeing a young kid be so uh so
passionate about what he's doing is
pretty dope so I mean we got up we mean
a road record and they responded to it
and Chris and Justin kind of had a
little competition about who could who
could write a cool advice for and they
turned out pretty good so all right
we'll see man no names yet but there's
definitely some exciting and different
features and more to come so you know
we're just trying to give people a lot
of option is this going to be a record
that Bieber and Chris Brown a wrap it on
or singing we'll see we'll see okay
we'll find out that's what it is is the
album still called is this too orange as
this too orange man comes out in March I
wouldn't be surprised if it gets pushed
back because that's just like one of
those things but now we're shooting for
March I really think is going to come
out March early March at that we're
going to try to really attack March
Madness I'm a big college basketball's
we're going to we're going to really try
to attack spring break as well what is
uh what is the story behind the title
man is this George kind of just hit me
man but it's really about colors and
music and respects to you know pops and
jazz feels very purple and blue you know
and then you have is this too orange
which feels it's warmer it's it's red
it's yellow and and I think that's
what's really fun for me is to kind of
do different stuff and use multiple
outlets use releasing music on Twitter
and releasing music on facebook and then
also having music on the radio and if we
can cover a lot of ground like that
where we r you know all over the
Internet
all over the mass bright you we're in
good shape so uh yeah we're just using
our using our tools wisely and and
that's really it so is this too orange
come just hit me half asleep and orange
Oh al shouts on dildo did a lot of the
the production on on asleep in the bread
aisle he and I have really kind of grown
up together and progressed together as
well so I'm excited for everybody here
his new work oh and and building off of
the foundation that we created with
really the greenhouse effect beautiful
hey I also would like to thank you for
being the only rapper I know that has
ever referenced blumpkins in a rafa haha
nicely I was just I was just pretty
geeked out about the Magnus ver
Magnusson one recently i love i love
Larkin my go-kart marks but but we
always at my old station we always have
like an inside joke about getting
blumpkin to [__] and when that came out
he said ash rock the king of the
blumpkin oh man that was our joy broadie
odd don't out now do not know what a
blumpkin is urbandictionary.com
urbandictionary.com yes most definitely
um another thing I wanted to ask you man
as far as you know you to me you're one
of the nicest on the mic um but I think
you're really underrated do you feel
like you're underrated as a rapper man
it's all subjective too I have people
who like out your honor and I are so
it's really kind of a subjective I know
that we've put a lot of work in I know
that it's obvious that we've inspired
some of the young kids and that's all
that matters to me is that we are
contributing yeah you know I'm saying so
as long as we're contributing and it's
not just take take take take take we're
actually give them back and doing some
cool stuff and and giving giving the
kids something that they can relate to
that's important to me because obviously
hip-hop has changed drastically since I
was young you know and the kind of hole
now it's turned into this whole kind of
get rich quick scheme and stuff we've
been doing for the past 10 years very
devoted to the radio and stuff like that
and almost completely changing genre
it's nice to just get back to music with
a message and as long as we can do that
and people recognize that that's all
that's important definitely get ready
it's a new day that we met here man that
was a great song is that is that I mean
I've songs like over a year old now is
that going to be on the album
it needs to be reborn man aside great
rest such a great record we have a we
have special guests on the remix of it
so but yeah I think I think that one
will pop back up man but we perform that
one people go nuts so it's really then
that was a really interesting thing for
me to put that record out because when i
put it out man i love it i thought i was
like this is it blows you know what to
be honest with you man that really
showed me the power of labels and that's
why I'm still willing to cooperate with
major labels because if you can use
their resources and they're excited
about you you can do some really
powerful things but we have not sold the
record company on that record they're
like hey this is a great record that's
put it out but it didn't get that push
so it kind of hit a glass ceiling to
just my main audience so you know got a
thousand like a million views on on VEVO
or whatever and that was it right so uh
it kind of hit that glass ceiling and
but it's it was cool to see I mean we
performed it in Chicago and I saw the
video it's pretty much held the mic out
kids in all the words so and it's got
one of those legendary openings where
you just play it and somebody knows what
it is so uh yeah man that's it just
trying to make good music that's really
all comes down to know algorithms that's
what's up man how did you choose what
MCS work with on patch and Jess I know
she had Casey Veggies on their blue
which is like kind of a diverse ya know
and I mean all those it's just uh that
was one thing that was super important
about perhaps and jazz is the communal
aspect of it and bringing in a lot of
people from different walks of life
right kind of doing different
generations of rounders as well and
that's just it's just one JP obviously I
worked very very closely the kids in the
blender babies in Chicago yeah you know
it's a hub there Chicago's a hub and
rocky fresh all those ppl rushes the
kids these days and it's just a group of
like-minded individuals man every time
we we link up with these guys 12 you
from the inside mom and all these kids
when we get in the same room when we
talk and chop it up we're all on the
same page or just like man we just want
to do something so cool we just want to
have this one I just want this to be dub
I don't even want to worry about this
other stuff so you know Bronson gets on
a record and that's just because we both
like you know a big wrestling fans and
all that and then some and I've spent a
lot of time in New York and I think when
when Bronson jumped on the track and
being out in New York hip-hop right now
action is probably one of my favorite
rappers ya know he's dope he is dead why
he's just though the static selectively
well done album is crazy see you no
matter dr. Lecter's crazy he's got a
million projects coming out too and I'm
just like thrilled for him because he's
dope and he just doesn't take himself
too seriously great which here gets a
super important trait in an MC yeah it's
a very important quality so when that
happened I think a lot of people
understood what we were trying to do and
and it just they just spawned like hey
let's we really we recorded that we
recorded that all those sessions in
three days in LA because I didn't have a
car so I was just stranded JP came over
we did about 17 songs on rounds which is
crazy that doesn't normally happen
that's not normally the output but I was
kind of kind of depressed so so to speak
and then uh and then you know we got all
these features again like probably six
days before the tape even dropped when
people are just like I want to be on
this record I want to be on this right
we just started handing it out and is it
was just special mental the whole way
the whole thing came together which is
very natural very organic and it's just
like supposed to happen in the kitchen
that's one of my favorite song has here
man that's what's up yet you know Chuck
another one of those dudes that's uh
that's family to me man that's one of
those guys who I support regardless and
he's doing some really cool stuff
there's a beat tape coming on top of the
year called working he's got some other
stuff he's working on a sounds like fun
project and yeah Chuck Chuck can't do
any wrong in my eyes many he does it for
the right reasons would I right people
he he played that be for me like you
came over he was working on a beat with
that bones took that for himself played
and I was just like wow that joint came
together about half an hour common
knowledge came together in about half an
hour and you can tell man because
there's no disconnect between vibe don't
listen like you're listen frontier yeah
it's a cohesive project for sure so
we're excited about it man so if you if
you guys haven't got it yet chap apps
and jazz trending worldwide on Twitter
it was man we got a trending worldwide
on Twitter it was really cool to see and
that's that's it we're working really
hard organically right now and just
getting back to things that really
matter and obviously look out for the
Def Jam release is this too orange and
there's going to be continual projects a
lot of videos a lot of fun to be had